sudanese political parties and the army
are coming together for talks they
haven't done this since the military
took power eight months ago the
participants say they want to end a
political impasse created by the
takeover which has left sudan without a
fully functioning government and in
political and economic turmoil the
united nations the african union and the
regional body igad are facilitating the
talks
the aim of this dialogue is to reach a
consensus on the constitutional
arrangements agree on a prime minister
and prepare for elections the tripartite
mechanism is only a facilitator it's up
to the sudanese who are the stakeholders
to decide on the outcome
sudan's transitional period was derailed
when the military took power last
october it dissolved a two-year
government that was meant to lead sudan
to democracy after three decades of
one-man rule under president omar
al-bashir it also sidelined the
political coalition known as the forces
of freedom and change with whom it had
signed a power sharing agreement after
bashir was forced out the coalition was
absent in wednesday's talks a group
which split from it and had called for
the military to take over attended
we've participated in this session to
agree on how the transition should be
and complete the transition period as
well as prepare for elections it is very
important we will also talk about how to
form a government to lead during the
remaining transitional period and
implement the peace deal signed we don't
want to sideline anyone and hope those
who are not attending will join prior to
the start of the talks the head of the
army issued a statement of unity
describing it as a historic opportunity
to achieve the demands of sudanese
people
i request all the concerned components
to respond to this dialogue and not
stand as an obstacle in the path of
democratic change and transition the
people and the country deserve to be put
above our differences and we should
place the unity and security of the
country above political and personal
desires
but the forces of freedom and change
coalition is not the only group that's
chosen not to attend
the groups known as resistance
committees which have been organizing
regular protests for months are also
absent from these talks they've been
vocal in their opposition to negotiate
or compromise since the military took
over last year
there were more protests on wednesday
against the military's rule more than
100 people have been killed in
anti-military demonstrations and
hundreds of others have been wounded
since the takeover those behind the
protests say only when the military is
removed from the equation will they be
ready to negotiate on how sudan's
transition to democracy should continue
hiba morgan al-jazeera khartoum